It's Labor Day and we're here, why are we
here?
We take federal holidays off.
We're here because we're trading Labor Day
for an entire week off.
Next week, we will be off all of next week.
Much needed for the staff and then back with
you for the debates and through the election.
But good thing we're here today because one
of the biggest stories of the last couple
of months in terms of its possible impact
on the presidential election broke over the
weekend, which has now been quadruply corroborated,
despite Donald Trump claiming it is all fake.
This is a story in which the Atlantic broke
a story claiming that officials who were on
a trip with Trump to France say that Trump
called troops who died losers and suckers.
And it is a hugely instructive story from
the perspective of the evolution of damage
control, because the initial story was just
in the Atlantic and it talked about Donald
Trump repeatedly disparaging the intelligence
of service members, saying keep wounded service
members out of military parades.
It wouldn't look good.
And it even goes on to say that I don't know
if you remember that incident in 2018 where
Donald Trump decided while in France not to
go and honor the troops at a cemetery near
Paris that it was because of rain.
And these individuals who have come forward
said it had nothing to do with rain.
Trump was worried his hair would look bad
if it got wet.
And he didn't think it was important again
to honor those who were losers and suckers,
quoting Trump as saying, why should I go to
that cemetery?
It's filled with losers.
Trump also during that trip referred to a
conversation sorry, during a conversation
referred to more than eighteen hundred Marines
who lost their lives at Bella Wood as suckers
for getting killed.
Now, Donald Trump came out and said it's all
fake.
Trump administration officials came out and
said it's all lies.
Except then the Associated Press corroborated
it.
Senior defense official with firsthand knowledge
of events and a senior U.S. Marine Corps officer
said to the Associated Press, the report in
the Atlantic is correct.
White House continued to insist it's fake
and it's phony.
And then CNN Tripoli corroborated it.
Donald Trump referred to fallen U.S. service
members in crude and derogatory terms during
that trip in November of 2018 to France.
And then they said it's all fake.
And then Fox News quadruply corroborated it.
Take a look at this.
This is Fox News now.
John, I've spoken with two senior U.S. officials
who are on the trip to France who confirmed
to me key details in the Atlantic article
and the quotes attributed to the president.
My source, a former Trump administration official,
told me when the president spoke about the
Vietnam War, he said it was a stupid war.
Anyone who went was a sucker.
The president would say about American veterans.
What's in it for them?
They don't make any money.
The source said it was a character flaw of
the president.
He could not understand why someone would
die for their country.
Not worth it.
Regarding the French trip to mark the end
of World War One, according to this former
official, the president was not in a good
mood.
French President Macron had said something
that made him mad.
He questioned why he had to go to two cemeteries.
Why do I have to do two?
His staff explained he could cancel, but he
was warned they the press are going to kill
you for this.
The president was mad as a hornet when they
did, according to this source, when asked
if the president could have driven to the
Ein Mahne cemetery.
This former official said confidently that
there was not a security reason to not to
drive to the cemetery, which is about 40 miles
from Paris.
Quote, The president drives a lot.
The other world leaders drove to the cemeteries.
He just didn't want to go.
Regarding the president's July 4th military
parade planning during a planning session
at the White House after seeing the Bastille
Day parade in 2017, President Trump said regarding
the inclusion of wounded guys, quote, That's
not a good look.
Americans don't like that.
Regarding Senator McCain, the president, according
to this source, just hated John McCain.
He always asked, why do you see him as a hero?
Two sources confirmed the president did not
want the flags lowered after McCain died.
But others in the White House ordered them
at half mast.
There was a standoff and then the president
relented.
That is Fox News corroborating and expanding
the story.
It's even worse than initially reported, actually,
based on Fox News's additional reporting.
I'm starting to think this story may be true.
And, of course, it tracks completely with
Donald Trump's brand.
And a lot of this stuff he came close to saying
in public, including about John McCain, the
late Republican Senator John McCain, who had
been captured and held as a.
Prisoner of war Donald Trump saying he prefers
soldiers who don't get captured and even tweeted
about it.
I'll tell you about that in a moment.
The internal chaos that this caused, that
Fox News, fascinating because you had at one
point within hours the opinion, people saying
this is all fake and the news side saying
we've been able to independently confirm these
reports.
And Trump fundamentally is not able to understand
the concept of someone doing something that's
not completely self-centered and greedy.
He has an inability to do that.
And, you know, when this story broke, you
had some people on the left saying, Trump
is right, these people are suckers.
Who the hell would join the military?
I do think it's important to distinguish between
supporting the troops and supporting individual
wars and what the military does.
I recognize, for example, that when George
W. Bush took us into the hairbrained, misguided
Iraq war, we didn't have a draft in which
I could have been drafted, potentially because
we have a volunteer army.
And people actually volunteer.
Now, we often send them to the wrong wars.
We use the troops in disgusting ways for political
battles.
The way George W. Bush did.
But nevertheless, I don't think it makes sense
to denigrate the individuals as the suckers.
We have a military industrial complex.
That is the problem.
We have a deranged foreign policy apparatus.
And, you know, if if you do believe that those
who go and fight are suckers tone down the
military apparatus.
Trump has done the opposite.
Trump simultaneously brags about making the
military bigger than ever, but then says that
the individual troops are suckers and losers
when they actually go and get killed.
And why is that?
It's because Trump doesn't care about the
individuals in the military.
But Trump is glad to use the military as an
institution for his benefit when he can.
It's very much on brand.
In fact, could this be Trump's 47 percent
moment?
Thinking back to Mitt Romney in the 2012 campaign?
It's possible this you know, a lot of these
things that happen don't directly relate.
They don't directly affect constituencies
that Trump needs.
This is a case where if you look at Florida
and the heavy military presence in Florida
and Florida being an important battleground
state where it could determine it certainly
is much more likely than Massachusetts or
California to determine the winner of the
presidential election, disparaging the troops
in this way to the extent that people will
believe it could actually make a difference.
And again, anybody doubting it, it's been
quadruply corroborated.
It tracks with things Donald Trump has said
publicly.
Remember John McCain, not a war hero because
he was captured attacking Goldstar family,
the Khan family.
This is only half a step further than what
Trump has done publicly.
And in fact, Donald Trump once did re tweet
that McCain is a loser.
Trump retweeting in 2015 an article from Fitz
News, Donald Trump.
John McCain is a loser.
Now the stand the perspective.
There was the election of 2008.
But Trump very critical of McCain, including
for having been captured.
And by the way, this is maybe the most interesting
thing Pete Buda judge has done.
He was interviewed on Fox News about this
story and he used Fox News's own confirmation
of the story while on Fox News against them.
Take a look at this again.
I'm looking at the Internet right now.
Fox News itself has confirmed many of the
details of this story.
So so the real question is not to me.
Did Trump do this?
It seems almost certain that he did.
The question is, number one, what else is
going to come out between now and November?
Because the Atlantic is saying there will
be much more, that this is only the tip of
the iceberg.
And number two, will this affect Trump with
constituencies he needs, like the military?
I believe that it could.
I want to hear from you.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Let me know what you think could be the impact
of
this story.